we got our third show on sale right now
at The Gramercy theater let's go the
army of garbage came correct in New York
City sold out two shows we added our
third links in the description let's
party baby Friday February 3rd we'll see
you there see you there welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that at the group to be
classy aren't there just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host take trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at Antonio's basement she's
upstairs getting ready to go skiing okay
yeah no snow in the forecast but she's
still hitting the slopes anyway all
right Mike co-host is coming at you from
right next to me real unamused not even
trying to hide it anymore
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman he is not to
be tripled with in the boardroom or the
bedroom give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan Hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate you
subscribe on iTunes full video of album
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
out over a hundred thousand baby uh and
obviously the greatest website of all
time patreon.com are you garbage check
it the [ __ ] out love that money and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
and twos crosses them T's and dots them
eyes give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dudes
hey T-Bone oh having a great holiday I'm
gonna have some traditional holiday tub
cheese this year yeah what's that the
stuff that Sarah makes in her tub
I thought it was some hillbilly [ __ ] you
have I know it's glassy
I was thinking like pimento so did I
I was like I think my mom
that's how
that's how it tub cheese I was like that
sounds pretty good I just pictured like
a big tub just slapping it on a rinse
crack
but gang we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guests back with us
again today uh one of our absolute
favorites we love her you love her an
amazing new podcast out right now called
Laney Journey give it up for our good
pal Sarah Bash
yeah hi guys hey you have I forgot about
that you do have every like podcast or
every other interview we do they go
what's one answer where you were [ __ ]
blown away and it's all we we always
give that answer you making the ricotta
cheese yeah at home
and an old t-shirt
y'all it's pretty good
smooth as silk I'll tell you that I'm
making cannolis are you making cannoli
no no
um an old pair of shoes
I've got some taco shells I'm gonna dust
some powdered sugar on
that probably wouldn't be that bad I
know I pictured it in my head when she
sounds like I would have mine that yeah
it's not bad it cannoli Taco
um since Toby brought that up I did want
to ask you all right we're in the
holiday season here a little bit uh is
there a tolomash family recipe appetizer
hors d'oeuvre dip anything like that
what's the spread looking like I'm
looking around out there well we we've
been doing a cheese board prior to the
meal okay but it's been annihilating the
main meal really yeah and then in the
past few years we do in Texas we'll just
do an outside barbecue love that okay uh
but this year I'm hosting the dinner
everyone's coming up and I'm making it's
are you our old traditional meal and
it's roast beef with Yorkshire pudding
ah
a traditional English you're doing this
in your apartment yes a one bedroom
isn't it uh yes with a kitchen
how many people you expecting uh 10
people so after 40 10 people and I've
never where's everybody gonna sit on the
couch well somebody's sitting on the
couch some dusks together
mismatched chairs we have an outside
picnic table that I have to bring in
welcome to the show ladies and gentlemen
eating Christmas dinner inside on lawn
furniture that's what I'm talking about
please bring the umbrella in as well
open that thing up I think I'm just
gonna try to be like a bee's nest on
that or something you're gonna have to
power wash that before that thing comes
I was yeah I'm just gonna bring it in as
is and let it fly rustic well one time
we went to do a barbecue at Bobby
Kelly's house in Westchester and
Infamous barbecue he had was so proud
that he cut up these wood stumps but he
didn't seal them and so we at during the
Hang all of a sudden we were covered in
spiders
spiders and sap
I have another hot dog and some raid
please
but it's nothing like when someone's so
proud of they're like don't you love
these rustic chairs that I made and
you're like we're covered in spiders a
woodpecker's just drilling into the side
of your head
foreign
okay have you cooked a meal this big
before for anybody no no I haven't I do
cook I think the biggest piece of meat
I've cooked is a pork shoulder okay
that's a pretty that's a that's a big
how big is this pot roast gonna be it's
got to feed 10 people so I'm thinking
it's gonna be this it's big okay I'm
assuming it's gonna be over a hundred
dollar piece of meat is that the meat
you asked where can you get a nice piece
of meat yes okay all right you've done
no research on this meal she just asked
is there anywhere to get meat around
here is what she is you guys know where
Yorkshire is by any chance like you find
out my roast beef is just one big
hamburger patty
that's what you should do make a
meatloaf or something you're rolling a
dice in a roast beef yeah I am worried
because the time that I made the pork
shoulder I thought starting at eight
o'clock at night was the right time and
I think I finished it at like two in the
morning wait for dinner yeah wait you
started cooking dinner that night at
eight o'clock were you supposed to eat
that night or the next day I was gonna
eat that night here's the thing that's a
late dinner to begin with all my hours
are late what are you Spanish
your grandmother's Keeling over in the
corner and she had a water insulin shot
in she gotta wait till 3 A.M no I don't
know if you guys get this and I don't
know all of a sudden you want to do a
big project late at night like for some
reason I only want to hammer stuff to my
wall at midnight
yeah you're just like I'm gonna do this
right now sure yeah and I didn't know
that these are meats that have to be
slow cooked slow cooking Meats yeah yeah
yeah I was always like like that in
school like in in like elementary school
and high school I would have like my
most like creative energetic periods
when I was supposed to go to bed at like
nine or ten again you're like a dog
running around the living room she's
jumping off to couch and stuff and then
I'd wake up the next morning and be
miserable and wouldn't have any of that
creativity or drive or anything so I get
what you're saying with that but who who
are you with the pork shoulder who were
you making that for Joe and I oh you
were just making dinner for yourself
yeah well it was during covet and I just
got and I I like cooking I don't think
I'm great at it but I like like it roll
the dice well here's I do the recipes
and then I realize I don't know what
this ingredient is and then I look up
the substitution online and then
sometimes I don't even have that and I'm
like I think this is similar to this
just start freestyling a little bit Yeah
my wife does the same everything has
cinnamon in it dude a little paprika can
save a lot
oh man a little paprika you know what
really really uh cures all is that
everything uh blend for everything bagel
did you put that yeah Sesame and onion
covers all the bases bro it doesn't
matter everything but the bagel yeah so
you cook the the shoulder it's not done
until two o'clock but it's just you and
him that's big you can't do that with
Christmas no so I'm gonna start or like
at 10 in the morning look up how long
you have to slow cook I think it's three
hours but here's the thing too sometimes
I don't read the directions until day of
oh you're doomed you are doom I was
supposed to start three hours ago and
then they'll be like have the meat
resting for two days and you're like oh
[ __ ] yeah usually you want to have the
meat rest for at least a half an hour
covered that's so I gotta take it out
I'm gonna put it on the box first I
gotta buy it first just get some roast
beef slices or something like that
I think a half a pound slice fish make
yourself some sandwiches
[Music]
real thing
so then you can barely see it
okay let's start here so remember we can
help you out a little bit do you have
um do you have a knife that can cut a
roast beef a shark I'm just realizing I
don't okay yeah you gotta have that is
it one of those ones that you get
batteries for
which hold on someone I my family uses
at the Carver turkey oh yeah it's not
batteries you plug it in yeah
somebody said that's real I thought it
was the epitome of class that was like
now once somebody says somebody said it
this year and it blew my mind yeah and I
go I think that's pretty [ __ ] it
makes a weird smell dude
that electric motor
that burns something different sounds
like a train going by it does smelly
when that thing got fired up when I was
a kid we would stand around like it was
goddamn fireworks yeah well my step dad
breaks that out to carve the turkey oh
yeah it's like he's breaking out of a
[ __ ] Samurai everyone watch out I got
the sword gun I love that it's from page
news am I you should get one of those
yeah right we have a set of knives for
you actually of course yeah
yeah
um all right so you want to have the
knife to cut it yeah you have the pan
the cooking and you think I got it at TJ
Maxx last night man I love to okay the
Finish is going to come off that pan
that's happened to me I did worry about
that I looked at the pan and like
there's paint on this yeah do you know
what I mean where it's red you're like
why is this pan red let me ask you this
but it has that thing that you propped
the meat on so the drippings ah so it
doesn't sit and it's dripping sure sure
like a dirty like a dirty [ __ ]
roast beef slipping off look at you you
disgust me
I'm taking a bath in your own fill juice
that get in there clean yourself up we
got company coming over to eat at patio
furniture
do you have a meat thermometer
I think I do it came with my slow cooker
so I gotta get batteries for it okay
okay yeah these are things you don't
know until you start cooking sure okay
well it's gonna take you about six and a
half hours to cook this is it really did
you look it up I did I think it's per
pound oh my God I I'm glad uh you told
me that because I was gonna start at 10.
what would okay I gotta start earlier
yeah oh my God what's a good thing he
came and did the podcast we just [ __ ]
Saved Christmas
thank you you're welcome to lamashes
hold on a second
10 people how big of a pot roast does
she need T-Bone
yeah uh uh nine pounds I don't know man
that's what I was thinking a pound of
meat per person
that's a lot I say a lot of me that's
gonna be a virus
[Laughter]
this is how I was talking about this
I buy [ __ ] online like Amazon being like
Oh yeah that's 23 centimeters and then I
realized I don't know what 23
centimeters looks like it might be my
favorite person in the world I love you
oh my God
I'll keep you posted the sheer
confidence yeah I'm doing a traditional
uh British Christmas no idea you have
enough plates and all that stuff yes I
bought here you guys are gonna like this
no we're not
I don't want to do dishes so I got paper
plates that's okay
but I got real silverware
I would hope so that's probably gonna
rip through the place yeah
that's the only problem you're cutting
five plates
do you have one of those those Fork
things the the they look like the forks
prongs to like yes to pull the meat away
no to stick to stick it in it looks like
take a big fork guys no you got to get
one of those all right well I gotta do
all this stuff because you gotta go like
that and then you gotta cut the meat
yeah hey you're looking for eight to ten
pounds of roast beef yeah what are we
talking about a thousand bucks I'm
probably gonna come to the market with
twenty dollars in my hand
oh my God just give me some neck you got
any neck in there I'll cook up some
necks these idiots will know the
difference I do picture me calling for
Chinese food at the last sure pulling
out seamless or something yeah yeah on
the phone everybody get what you want
something I looked into catering but
nobody offered a traditional English
well how what's what's Yorkshire pudding
Yorkshire pudding is kind of like uh
like a flower pancake mixture cooked in
like the roast beef fat okay you do it
in muffin tin so you Ladle a little bit
of the fat I think you can also do
chicken fat so it's like this crispy
flavorless
mushy muffin but it's so good with the
gravy and then the other yeah okay you
know you have a handle on that you know
how to do that apparently I gotta do it
at the last 15 minutes this is a timing
issue that I I know it's a level of
difficulty that I'm not prepared for
they burn real easy yeah I might have to
do get a whole that of pancake mix and
keep going until you go you get one good
one out of each batch all right you're
gonna have sliced roast beef and
pancakes for Christmas I am panicking
nah you'll be all right just get your
stuff together I'm gonna do that today I
got four days ready you know a
professional chef of any kind yeah no no
give me like a quick rundown Maybe
YouTube get on YouTube I will do the
YouTube I usually kind of follow Allison
Roman but lately I've been I feel like
she cuts Corners I don't know who that
is you cut Corners what do you thinking
about the corners she's the queen of
cutting Corners she's always like I
don't take the stems off because I can't
be bothered and I'm like okay
[Laughter]
yourself
that's why I don't take the wrapper off
I just throw it in there and let my
guess unwrap it oh man that's wild
um and you guys are doing are you guys
doing presents your husband no because
Joe and I are doing presents sure but in
the family we do drawing so we're not
buying thousands yeah what do you guys
call it secret santa Pollyanna secret
Santa can you guys change gifts if you
want and do that kind of thing
um no we haven't done that Joe has
recommended that but I don't feel like
we come from a family that does that
start fights it does oh and we did it
once between my aunts and uncles and it
was like the goddamn Thunderdome yeah
people were fighting taking hiding
presents and [ __ ] it was bad well
somebody always comes in with is this
you bought this at the gas station on
the way here yeah and someone also
always buys like an iPod or something
yeah yeah yeah you get [ __ ] you get
[ __ ] hey everybody who buys the most
expensive gift always gets the worst
yeah yeah
stop at the gas station hey everybody
needs gum what are you gonna do what are
you getting joe
for Christmas okay well he's really hard
to buy because he makes money and he
always just buys what he wants for
himself sure okay and I feel like every
gift I've gotten him he never uses what
what has been on that list cornhole
travel cornhole and it's just been
unopened in the living room where would
he I was like let's play it outside on
the side behind her
um apartment because we got enough space
and he's like I don't want to disturb
the neighbors because New Yorkers are
difficult people it's very true if you
hear thumping on a repetitive level an
hour people get livid and it's also like
that could be affecting
a thousand people you know what I mean
they're like however many people are
around that yeah but you guys hang in
your backyard a lot right yeah when it's
warm outside yeah I don't think that's
come on I'm that way you moved to New
York yeah yeah that's what you get yeah
but I understand what he's saying it's
just like this for I mean it's you know
it's not quiet do you play music out
there when you're back there not really
whisper but Joe will like cigar smoke
back there there you go yeah huh all
right so that's one that's what so
that's one gift he um if I get him books
he but even that they just look
decorative yeah so I'm just annoyed
um so this year he sent me a link to
what he wanted nice and it's a uh this
graphic designer created uh images of
each Seinfeld girlfriend from the whole
series on a whole poster that's really
cool okay and so I bought that and then
I bought a frame on Amazon and framed it
and that's what I'm getting and then
I'll probably find some little treats
that he likes although now he's on a
diet kick okay so I can't get him any of
his treats huh okay that's good that's a
that's a good gift it's so difficult I
find your significant other is the
hardest to buy presents for I've struck
out every single year for the past eight
years yeah not one good gift no and like
I struck out with him two years in a row
did you
sometimes you're like you got me a
burden
why do you say I have to go run errands
now thank you he bought me uh he got me
this is already out he got me a gift or
two a thousand dollar gift certificate
for the Carnival Cruise Line I got him a
cruise
a cruise I gotta go on a cruise
how is that a burden that's not it's not
bad and I bought him that bass guitar
back there but you have to fly to
Florida now
that's the burden I gotta fly to Florida
I gotta fly to Florida to get on a boat
to go four hours to get off at Tijuana
or whatever for for 35 minutes get
yelled at that I don't miss the boat get
back on and do that three times you can
take it here and take the cruise up to
Boston yeah or that's my other option is
to get on a New York and go to Boston
get a cup of shouting Providence is
beautiful this time of year we're just
there
now my I like it I when people get you
artwork and it's not framed oh that's
yeah it's like okay now yeah I think
most gifts most if you added up all the
gifts that are exchanged over the
holiday season at any given year I would
say most of them are unused sure yeah I
always think is this person gonna like
this or is this gonna end in trash
island in the middle of the ocean oh
yeah I also I'm I'm like Joe I'm like I
don't want if I want something I'll just
bought like I just bought like gifts
have always lost on me yes because and
he's like that too he's like I get you
gifts all year round yeah we just buy
stuff yeah of course and then so why do
I need to and I'm like no I agree
I buy you whatever you want you dumb
[ __ ]
I gotta eat cold pot roast
get it together woman embarrass me in
front of this family I'm to cook pot
roast what's the best cook the best gift
any of you guys have ever gotten
I got asked that question and I still
can't even I don't know I genuinely
don't know ever in my life Joe got me a
computer that saved my life there you go
laptops yes
I did it was a Dell it was a year ago
you write your letters on there yeah I
was so poor not that long it was a
couple of years ago that I needed a
computer and I only had like I got a 200
gift card to list like Best Buy or
something I bought a desktop dude it
worked at the speed of [ __ ] molasses
it was so slow I think I turned it on
twice
oh we could well if it's a PC it takes
forever to boot up because it's got all
the anti-virus software I don't think I
ever bought the software I was just raw
dogging the internet for a while so hold
on I come that's that's something that
you would use yeah because it improves
your life yes yes you would use that
every day yes yes
um my the best gift I ever got was one
year out of nowhere one of my uncles
just broke us off a Jihad that's crazy
and I was about I was about 22 and I oh
that's the greatest I was hemmed up yeah
I was in a real bad spot that literally
what do you mean
just after you know you do the presents
and then maybe your parents have a
little hidden one yeah oh and then she
my mom came up and she I thought I was
done because it was real like that year
on Christmas Eve for my aunts and uncles
and she just came over and just [ __ ]
hit she's like and this is from your
Uncle Joe and boom [ __ ] whoa yeah
that was a lifesaver Game Changer Game
Changer yeah I was in I was in I would
have been physically
I had some wrong people some money you
got a bonus
yeah and then I got to one year I got
the GI Joe headquarters and that was
probably my greatest president of all
time I played with that [ __ ] thing
for like three years straight
shout out to it I got a mini bike like
the one that dumped like the exact one
in Dumb and Dumber like the little red
one that they ride yeah that's pretty
good I was eight my mom did not want me
to have it my parents were divorced my
dad bought it for me they're like really
Ram it you know yes give it to her I
crashed it the first day and like [ __ ]
my arm up [ __ ] my leg up my mom was so
mad I couldn't tell me [ __ ] though I was
cruising dude
I might as well been in the [ __ ]
Hell's Angels one arm and everything
just sipping down the street here comes
Kippy look out I was taking my helmet
the school to show off I am walking with
it under my eye like a motorcycle
parking is around
man did you know anybody that rode a
motorcycle to high school no that's
crazy I think there was a couple that
guy beats his dad up
a motorcycle to school you hate your dad
[ __ ] you say [ __ ] yeah we had a couple
of those dudes parked it right at the
door I feel like those guys are like 22
year old seniors yeah they hit puberty
earlier too yeah held back early like
kindergarten yeah they've always been
home yeah did first grade three times
yeah yeah sure
I love those guys yeah those guys were
all right what did you did you drive to
school did you walk to school was it a
bus what were you doing I uh my brother
had a car so he would drive me to school
that's big yeah and that was that was
nice how much older is he than you four
years so when I was a freshman you drive
and then by the time I got my license uh
my dad I Got a Car nice yeah so you
drove yourself Tercel so you never had
to do the high school bus
no and I didn't live that far that if I
I couldn't drive to school I would ride
my bike
really yeah like wow I like the bike
riding I still do it it's like something
out of a movie yeah riding your bike to
school you would skidding what's up
8 59. no I wish I could get in never
skid it in couldn't skit either no it's
a big skitter never skip it it's hot
that's hot could you write could you
ride it with no hands I could do no
hands really that's pretty good did you
no that's why I asked everybody that
question oh you couldn't ride a bike
with no hands what are you talking about
my center of gravity was all [ __ ] up
lean my head on the [ __ ] on the
steering wheel now I never had a 10
speed like that either yeah you didn't
need a 10 you could do it on a BMX bike
wow I thought you had to be a 10 speed
I'd say it had to be a 10 speed you had
to be Italian and in really good shape
to do that yeah 100 wearing a wife
beater or no shirt and you'd ride down
the street like that
it took a while so you could pedal with
no hands yeah but like you could cruise
down a hill or whatever you could do
that's how you start it's like training
wheels you know get a bike we'll teach
you all right that'll be on patreon.com
folks there you go
um speaking of patreon let's do a couple
of cues sure we got a couple here a
couple of cues
oh patreon guys as you know when you
join the patreon we will answer your
garbage question on the air it's just
the best way to do it
um there was a couple uh there's a
couple ones
seeking advice from a lady so it or
about a relationship so it'd be nice to
get your your perspective here
um this one's from uh Soggy Bottom me
and my girl broke up last week on good
terms is it garbage to return the
expensive gift I got her and give her
something much cheaper for Christmas why
are you giving her a present anyway
that's weird that's suspect to me I
guess if it's good terms it's still like
uh my thing is do it why do you have to
tell people do you know what I mean like
he could just return it and get a
cheaper gift and she would not be none
the wiser yeah if they were together for
a couple years yeah I think he was just
asking us I don't think he's gonna go
tell well it's gonna get you this I got
your tennis bracelet so you slept with
Steve here's a portable cornhole before
I still want to be friends though
uh yeah I would don't give her anything
expensive I would think of I would give
that same advice to a girl too yeah yeah
sure that's [ __ ] stupid but also too
I mean as a guy you break up
to go ahead and give her a gift she's
[ __ ] somebody that's all I'm saying
that's real simp isn't that am I using
that correctly you are indeed yeah it's
real Sim [ __ ] but I also can't relate
because I've never had a relationship
that ended on good terms I try not to
end relationships near the holidays
because it gets complicated and I
remember always being annoyed about that
like [ __ ] [ __ ] Christmas is coming sure
can't break up with him well it's one of
his birthday is around the corner gotta
make a move well you're still with Joe
between his birthday Flag Day Christmas
Thanksgiving I'm screwed here in July
what are we doing yeah there's no way
out
this cold-hearted [ __ ] dumped me on
Mother's Day do you believe that two
weeks two weeks before Mother's Day you
know I love my mother
have you had relationships that ended on
good terms
um I feel like they always initially end
on good terms and then as time goes by
you you find Details sure and then
you're like ugh [ __ ] that okay yeah yeah
I've never had it never had why I mean
why would a relationship end on good
terms in My Dysfunctional brain yeah I
can't wrap my head around that yeah
because if it was on good terms why are
you breaking up yes yeah I think if
you're too mature
self-reflective people or whatever and
you're just like yeah it's just not what
it was or what it is or whatever like
it's best if we go both ways it doesn't
mean it doesn't hurt or whatever but
like I can understand it hmm
I don't know you're talking about mature
and all that stuff that's true yeah I've
had the door slammed in my face all my
stuff in trash bags that's how I like to
break up yeah walking out the door
crying yeah I'm sorry they were not
sorry
I'm sorry your credit's gonna go up
I won't be breaking Furniture in your
apartment have fun with a real man
who has a job
and a car and a 401k they need me I'll
be at my mother's
shout out to Bareburger keeping us alive
baby who's gone downhill who has I think
Bareburger has bear Burgers she came in
with that's going down yeah
podcast aside that's going down I
haven't had it in a while but when I
worked there the place was [ __ ]
blood-ish yeah not anymore okay I
haven't been in a long I don't know I
haven't been in a long time
I feel like Shake Shack just visually
has gone down because it's everywhere
now like it can't be good anymore I
liked it as my special thing go get
Shake Shack yeah that was my celebratory
meal the one in Madison Square Park yeah
I love that man that was a good one
although you have to keep your legs up
because there's rods I almost picked one
the other night keep your legs up that's
the only restaurant where like they just
cannot have rats there
and not get closed down yeah that's true
it's in the middle of a park people
doing Tai Chi oh yeah there's there's
always some sort of Silent protest going
on yeah
the squirrels are real Shifty in that
Park too I don't know what it is over
there yeah they're aggressive yeah that
park because yeah that's in the middle
of this [ __ ] that's like one square
block so if you're in there you gotta be
you know I used to work around I used to
walk dogs around there and so I would
observe the economy sure it's just us
and nannies oh yeah just Jamaican
nannies and white dog walkers yeah it's
grabbing a crinkle cut fries living the
life shout out to them oh this is inside
baseball but what is your uh because we
live in the same neighborhood what is
your Chinese spot over there the story
that you would go to I just do the first
one on GrubHub so it's East Garden I
don't ever go to a Chinese restaurant
unless Han Dynasty because I like
Schezwan man that place is [ __ ] yes
if you're in New York City was the
Second Avenue or Third Avenue I think I
think it's second who's that it's down
like 10th Street yeah yeah they do salt
and pepper shrimp that will blow your
brains out best fried chicken yeah
phenomenal yeah
be nominal I love that though like I
um growing up there was a couple like
actual like not fine dining but like
really nice Chinese restaurants where
you'd go and and you know like a
restaurant yeah you go and sit and eat I
feel like in New York you don't go to
where you order online no do you know
what I mean like you get there and it's
just like a murder scene yeah
like a bullet hole in the window yeah
like you know Christina Hutchinson used
to has a joke about that like you ever
be ordering from from a place from
seamless for like a year then you walk
by and you're like what the [ __ ] yeah
but there's there's obviously there's
good sit-in Chinese spots down in down
in Chinatown but in The Burbs I used to
love that yeah strip mall or something
good stuff they put the the good crispy
noodles on the table with the duck sauce
and the mustard I also like the wall
murals
and they're all right some cherry
blossoms and there was a place in my
hometown called Lele but closed down
after the pandemic it was [ __ ] nice
that place was bumping in the 90s yes on
a Friday and Saturday night let's go hmm
good [ __ ] put on your good outfit we're
going to we're going to lilies next to
Johnny's Number One Auto Sales that's
probably what my mom called it we're
going to that lilies
all right
um this one is from Jason have you ever
been a fan a fan of the band Buckcherry
that's tough that's the crazy [ __ ] yo
crazy [ __ ] you heard Joe's story about
that right I think did he do it on the
podcast yeah I don't think I've ever
talked about it I'm telling another
story but if you ever see him he had a
one-night stand with the lady that
[ __ ] him to Buck Cherry and she kept
sinking and she kept calling him a nerd
oh my God my God yeah
yeah Buck Cherry that's you're crazy
who's Buck Cherry you're a crazy [ __ ]
so good they're on top of it it's like
the trashiest song I don't know it yeah
really never heard it it's a song that
you fall off a mechanical bull to yes
yes all right yeah weighted tables the
trashiest girl would pull into the
parking lot blaring that yeah she was
late for her shift and she was waiting
on daycare
ah she was such a [ __ ] too especially
when you were new trying to figure out
the side work yeah uh she had no time
for you no but some reason you were in
love with her
I know I know exactly crazy
like Tara or something like that oh my
God what is it with Tara's parents
they're Terrors yeah para Works to
brunch shift and only the brunt shift
yeah and only the brunt shift
um all right this one's from David you
ever [ __ ] with Mexican jumping beans
which I don't remember as a kid yes why
were they real beans I don't know no
they're like they've got like a little
worm in them that pops yeah it's a worm
in there yeah or is it an actual kind of
thing yeah you don't eat them I feel
like it was along the line of like the
pet rock error or the sea monkey thing
it seems like it was the water thing
yeah although I never I don't think that
was a little bit before my time those
are they kind of came back a little bit
when I was a kid or maybe like when when
I was in like maybe High School the
younger my my friend's younger brothers
were getting them when they like kind of
see them in the 90s yeah aren't they
like fleas or something dude they got
out of hand real quick they [ __ ] it
was wild yeah I don't even know what sea
monkeys are dude they would grow and
they'd have the little magnified shrimp
yeah they're like marketing term for
brine shrimps yeah those novelty
aquarium pets
I got my dad one of those that lasted
like years did you get your dad sea
monkeys I bought him a little
self-contained ecosystem and then he it
lasted way longer than it should have
lasted and then
um it died and then yeah and then I got
him another one and then the the office
blinds fell on top of it and killed it
wait hold on a second they were sea
monkeys just no like Brian brine shrimp
they're like those little tiny shrimp
like that okay but in their
self-contained ecosystem so it's in a
glass with water and like a little bit
of green algae and it all like all like
the algae eats this that eats that
create the oxygen for the brine shrimp
yeah you know what's kind of cool I've
never seen them with uh with anything
living in it like any animals in it but
I remember for a while some parents
would have like the the sustaining
ecosystem where it was like there was
dirt there was like some plants in there
and it was sealed so it's the same thing
you were talking about and it would yeah
like Mediterranean yeah but there was
nothing in there I thought that was cool
as [ __ ] oh yeah I'm a big fan no one I
knew how to put a GI Joe in there see if
we survived I feel like uh when you go
and used to buy pot on an apartment sure
they would yes exact sort of aquarium
exactly they would have yeah everything
was [ __ ] but sweet Entertainment System
yeah good TV good TV and then yeah like
and
then you're like is your grandmother in
the
oh yeah she's sleeping
she's just watching a wheel of fortune
in her room oh man ah is that your
oxygen tank
my pot was always the best experience
because you're like oh what is this yeah
sure I just want to buy it I don't want
to look at your action figures
who are you buying
every guy's trying to show you a weird
collection
he buying it off at nine-year-olds yeah
no it was always like you're like why
can't I just buy pot like a regular
transaction sure yeah you gotta go in
because so if you're going back in the
day like you kids out there you wouldn't
understand this but used to be illegal
believe it or not yeah and back in the
day you couldn't just roll up to the
person's house run in and grab it
because the local Smokies would be all
over you then they see the traffic
coming in so you had to handle it a
little I was hanging in my friend don't
just come in and leave yeah it looks
like an 18. and then they would like
they would they would roll one up or
[ __ ] you want a bong hit or whatever
then you talk to them like your best
friends for a half an hour and then you
[ __ ] leave and see them in a month
yeah the grandmother thing is really
funny though because that's so true she
was always just coughing and then my
friends Sticky's pretty good
girl that weed is loud son
I had a friend that on his first day at
work here in New York when we first
moved here he befriended the company
loser and the guy was like oh ask him if
you want to go on a lunch break and then
they drove all the way to the Bronx and
then he also smoked pot near his the
guy's grandmother that now I've just
been like I think that's every that's
every pot dealing sure moment sure yeah
it was always the there was an adult an
older adult in the house that you didn't
have to say hi to yes because normally
when you're walking how are you good to
see you yeah yeah get inside and if you
were chant or whatever yeah they looked
at you weird like if they ever came out
like in their in their uh house coat or
whatever it was you know what I mean
like hey Mrs Grand Casino how are you
good to see you where's Rusty yeah you
know really I don't know [ __ ] wild I
went in the back somewhere we were
smoking everybody was smoking weed at
this house I don't know who this it was
a girl that we worked with that went to
another school we worked at the
supermarket together for a couple like a
couple of [ __ ] winners we were and we
were smoking everybody's smoking we get
a airplane I didn't stay in separate
school and you work at a grocery store
no way she's still alive holy [ __ ] and
it was like it was her parents were like
hippies and like there was another like
two or three adults that were like kind
of there I think there was a guy living
at on the property it was real [ __ ]
weird and I remember they're already
sitting there smoking [ __ ] uh like
three foot bongs and I had beer in the
car and yeah I'm like I'll just go grab
and we're hanging out yeah and they were
like you can't you're not 21 you can't
you can't have that beer I'm like dude
this guy's got a [ __ ] zong going
right now I can lay off the bubbler I
know they're like in a heroin
out of their mind and you're like no bud
lights in here oh yeah they wear Bud
Lights doing gravity bongs out of a
toilet I know what the [ __ ] I can't have
a glass of chardonnay like a [ __ ]
gentleman my one boy in high school man
one of my really good friends for some
reason his parents had a tenant that
lived in the Attic yeah it was like a
little apartment but you had to go
through the house yeah to get there so
like every once in a while we just be
like they're chilling on the couch or
like eating dinner this house and
[ __ ] Randy would just come roll it
through and [ __ ] just done not say
anything yeah like we weren't really
don't always say hi to your neighbors
man yeah we weren't real
sometimes you're late for work I think
one of my buddies said hello to him one
time and the my buddy my other buddy's
dad was like just yeah let him do his
thing you have to say hi yeah yeah he
[ __ ] walked he's stupid
don't talk to him unless you need knives
sharpened yeah I had a buddy live in his
addict
when we were in school in Heist Junior
High and high school that'd be sweet it
was cool but then like even when I was
up there I'm like this yeah isn't cool I
was like 15 I'm like could you see the
insulation no it was real small they act
like they it was like their own
apartment oh yeah yeah like they're
adults down at my mom's
that Dad wasn't around I'll tell you
that much I gotta run to my mom's and
get a snack
gotta run to the store real quick just
goes to the kitchen
there's a bodega downstairs all right
should I go to the laundromat
yeah I remember being like and he would
cover it with this uh like they're like
pretty cool huh yeah yeah we can split a
sing that was another thing we could
split cigs yeah we couldn't have two
going at a time sure yes we could eat
chicken you know and you have to like
hold your head out the way yeah it's
never comfortable and they try to make
it seem like it's so chill let's just go
outside and smoke we're allowed to you
know what I mean not to mention probably
300 degrees up there this summer yeah
[ __ ] he's playing some like he's
playing some Bone Thugs and Harmony or
something like the B side I'm like dude
this sucks man I know you're like we
might as well just be smoking crap
this is so depressing sure there's like
a Bob Marley towel as a curtain sure
yeah there's a bead type thing yeah the
setup back in the day it was it you it
made you feel that's why every time I
smoke weed or or anything out in public
I feel like I'm doing something yeah it
feels dirty yeah yeah
I remember like I had a boyfriend that
would smoke weed all the time and he
would be perpetually cleaning out his
bowls with paper clips and I was like I
just feel like I'm living with a heroin
music I know yeah it's so sad that resin
though man when you were out of weed
that [ __ ] would [ __ ] you up and they're
so proud of it oh you get a [ __ ]
thing like in the coal mines
they're like they're trying to shake
your hand get the [ __ ] out of here man
I'm gonna [ __ ] crackhead go buy a
dime bag
man sometimes you were hemmed up
get some dignity
sometimes you were hands up and you
gotta get [ __ ] yeah posted that [ __ ]
would [ __ ] level you too I would hate
something like you sleepy and when I so
when I was living here I'd have to go
back and I would go to Philly for like a
show or whatever I'd stayed a buddy on a
buddy's couch and I mean the table I
would sleep on the couch and you'd wake
up you like be like eating breakfast or
something like go to the Bode get a
brick bacon egg and cheese like open it
up I'd be eating on this coffee table
that had like an ounce and a half a
shake and dog hair and I'd [ __ ] res
balls I hated it it was the [ __ ]
worst the tools the homemade tools that
you found to do your res balls it would
be like a one of those screwdrivers for
eyeglasses yes oh that thing's a frisbee
to keep keep your seeds in line
your seeds now like they're not all over
the place I'm going to germinate those
guys shut up you loser
loser I had a roommate who did a gravity
bong hit of resin and it was just laid
out on the kitchen coughing going it's
not worth it
hit him with the narcane let's go I
don't know man that's what you're
looking for
Saturday afternoon another name game's
over what are we doing
that's a [ __ ] knockout punch
oh dude
when you're hanging out with pot smokers
they never sell it when you watch them
you're like you're not selling this [ __ ]
to me really well like oh yeah of course
yeah now I think it's a little bit
different but back then
Vapes look cool yeah yeah
relax you're going out you're doing your
day it's nice it comes in nice packaging
yeah strawberry flavor yeah yeah
we're promoting drug use
show is already garbage it's legal
that's legal it's not it's medicinal
it's with this you're afraid to fly get
high yeah your high school kid you got
cataracts do what you gotta do
how you doing
straighten yourself out
that gravity bong of resin seems all
right though I'll tell you that man
that's how you're gonna go out dude
that's what's gonna finally get you a
[ __ ] grab bong of resin i title this
ball or was it No One's Gonna call it no
one's gonna call the EMT either because
there's the yeah the house is loaded
with drugs old three liter of Mountain
Dew [ __ ] slice that in half man yeah
I remember we kept a bucket for Gravity
bungs back in the woods
and like getting fresh water to like you
know it was tough and we went
laughs
training to be a ninja so worth it what
are you doing nothing just filling up
our gravity bong broomstick full of
buckets
headed into the woods with my Stoner
Buddies
all right bye
get Dad who's oblivious all right have
fun kids
laughs
they're good kids going out there water
in a place down watering the trees in
the middle of the woods huh
you might get a grow operation just like
you're going to work at the factory
yeah uh but um we went in the bucket had
tadpoles in it
and that does it get self-sustaining
economy in there and they had tadpoles
in it in this one kid you still took it
I I mean I did it yeah it was one kid
did it's a rite of passage
if you slurp of a tadpole it's seven
years good luck
damn dude what the [ __ ] you just jammed
up man what do you want for me hit the
hose or something
oh God my head hurts I'm laughing this
is a [ __ ] this is an all-timer
um all right let's see here this is
another uh gift this is from Sam I got a
gift question for you is it garbage to
forget to take off the price tag on my
wife's new necklace the tag says 700 but
I paid 139 online I like it I like it
yeah Flex a little bit I don't have to
show you what it could have been you
know I guess it is worth 700 right sure
yeah if somebody did something
laughs
yeah I don't I used to for some reason
I'd never really understood that because
my mom was big Tech guy if if if my mom
ever gave a gift and it had to tag I'm
embarrassed they're so amazing oh my God
I'm so sorry I was even as a little kid
would be like yeah Flex on these [ __ ]
a little bit so it's also like
we know you didn't spend 14 Grand like
you bought a gift for your uncle or
something it's it's it's it's a polo
shirt 32 bucks it's it's 51 it's not
like the Marshalls tag ah the Marshalls
tags bad woody I it does feel not good
to buy a gift from Marshall you
shouldn't because no it doesn't belong
nothing there belongs there it all ended
up there and then it doesn't if they
don't sell it there they burn it
somewhere
it's used to heat homes it's a control
fire they do I their homeware is good
but it feels like giving a gift from
Marshalls feels like an insult sure of
course they need to do a rebranding I
think that's that's when you take the
tags off yeah that's when you I take
yeah you take the whole thing not just
the price yeah because I've gotten them
where [ __ ] where it just said
Marshalls but they ripped the price on a
lot of at least know what I'm dealing
with here what was it originally
it's irregular is what it is
um
but the thing is because nobody goes to
Marshalls going I'm gonna get Sarah X
yeah you see something there for cheap
you go I'll give this piece of [ __ ]
you know what I mean there's no actual
like she's all smoked up she won't know
the difference anyhow she's been smoking
tadpoles all weekend
yeah that's why I think it's just like
it seems like secondary to me oh my God
just grabbed this because I saw it and
was like oh this will check them out
sure yeah which I've done a lot of
course yeah most of my gifts especially
for the kids it's like just give them
something that they can open up and play
with for 10 minutes and I go all right
I'm done yeah yeah
but I feel like they sell Locker sets
there
as Marshalls at Marshalls in the
kitchenware sometimes it'll be a Ramekin
that you can't use for anything but I
like a little tiny one yeah but you're
like okay
yeah yeah yeah that's I hear aren't
there stories about people like finding
like really good sneakers at like
Marshalls and TJ Maxx every once in a
while sure but they're all they all end
up there for some irregular they they
couldn't be they weren't sold or they
couldn't be sold in regulars like they
were it's like molested good yes
Goods with a criminal record couldn't
get a real job uh Macy's wouldn't touch
me
got banned yeah if you ever buy fruit
sometimes they sell food products if
you're buying food from Marshalls or TJ
Maxx I like a good Jam there you can get
some jams that's old for sure that's old
I'll say this too I've said this before
in this broadcast TJ Maxx they've
they've upgraded a little bit they're a
little classier than Marshalls TJ Maxx
at Home Goods they have candy like it's
like festive candy like something you
would like give to someone sure sure
that shit's [ __ ] banging you get some
salted caramel chocolate in like a box
or something yeah they have like good
chocolate covered pretzel types yeah
I'll give you that for sure but
Marshalls just seems
it's like a bomb on it it's like my
fights I went to the one in Astoria TJ
Maxx yesterday
wild it's crazy Mars Nothing yes okay
nothing's where it should be underwear
in the food sure Sebastian has that
great one of my favorite jokes of all
time because how are people shopping in
there
so good
it's wild it's it's actually yeah my
wife tries to go because there's one in
my neighborhood uh right next to a gap
so like we'll go if we need like
whatever you know just a pair of jeans
or someone like let's go to Marshalls
and you walk in it's like it's always
nighttime in there and stuff it's bad I
thought the one on Ditmars was was
actually a nicer one they're putting a
Target across the street
um I'm excited for that uh I it's I
guess full Target or one of the mini
ones yeah I think it's one of the many
ones I hate that I can't do Target in
the city though anything in the city
stinks it's a nice parking lot a wide
diet a full selection or whatever yeah
okay we gotta go get out of Vernon
Boulevard go to that Costco over there I
like the Costco yeah that place is all
right maybe I should get my Meats there
there you go that's where you should get
your meat yeah at Costco yeah you should
get a roast over there no yes there's a
go to the butcher shop down the street
face through the nose they don't make
any money on their rotisserie chickens
it's just like a thing you can get while
you're there like they don't make any
profit from it sure yeah not wild
Tick Tock
I'm taking a bath yeah they're talking I
spread it everywhere but they're famous
for their road though yeah I don't know
if I ever had a I don't know if I've
ever had a Costco rotisserie yeah me
either I do love a good road do you like
a nice rotisserie chicken I love a
rotisserie chicken yeah I'm broth out of
it out of the afterwards it's already
seasoned up for you yeah yeah I thought
of that I keep my vegetable scraps in
the Breather toss it in with the carcass
wow get some water salt and pepper
you're good to go she's heavy on that
kind of stuff yeah reusing recycling my
food nothing's wasted at the toilet at
the list household
now and he doesn't eat what you make a
lot of the time no yeah he's got he's
just so you're just making it for
yourself yeah I just cook for myself
basically man I'm making soup for
yourself it's all week old man [ __ ]
after the three days you're gonna find
myself a goulash that's real sad it is
you're making soup for one
last forever this is so bored and I'm
like wanting to kill myself at the end
of the week where I'm like I gotta
finish this [ __ ] soup oh God that
bird can't die for nothing
what are you Native American
have you ever composted no I have
thought about it but I I've tried to do
it in my kitchen and then it ends up
being like dirt with like eggshells on
it and then I'm like it's just an ugly
Heap in the corner
I'm you know oh I know you mean yes yes
I guess so I have let go I'm trying to
let go of a lot of that [ __ ] of being
like you're that's not who you are
of the other person meaning like you're
not a composter sure and you're not
composting in New York like what are you
thinking you're no longer a person that
keeps their egg shells I'm no longer
making tub cheese okay when was the last
time you've done that probably like four
years ago okay that's not bad yeah
that's not bad I'm changing this is what
we talk about on lady Journey okay is I
the things that I don't know guys
probably do this as well but you get in
these kicks and you think your life is
going to be better like being crunchy or
something like crunchy very like
um composting okay making sure buying
thrifting instead of going to h m and
buying fast fashion sure and then you
realize it's a lot of work and who gives
a [ __ ] yeah just Burn It To The Ground
is what I say
I'm full on garbage
[Laughter]
with nothing to lose round of soup for
everybody huh
it's just pointless gotcha it's
pointless I'm with you yeah yeah I'm
wasting I'm wasting [ __ ] now I get it it
sounds fashion throw a whole rotisserie
chicken right out the [ __ ] window
[ __ ] out of here I tried the fast fast
that like I did watch a documentary on
something like that you're like oh wow
yeah that's really bad it is the h m
stuff what uh
because that now the h m is called Fast
fashion they've designed it used to be
like you would go shopping once a year
yeah for like I have to buy winter stuff
I gotta buy my jeans sure yeah now it's
like we they have they have you shopping
weekly yes like oh no these new things
just came out I gotta get this Trends
yeah it's like they're it's like every
two weeks yeah they have you buying and
then so it's like you buy the shirt you
wear three times you throw it out and
then people in Africa are just walking
over the [ __ ] that they probably made
six months prior yeah yeah it's bad it's
like a global thing I think they're like
the number one contributors to pollution
I think
specifically no just fast fashion and
like you're forever 21s your shins
gotcha yeah some new top comes out for
the summer and like the Hawaiian shirts
when they popped up sure yeah that's and
that's on the coast of Africa now or
probably somewhere in Chile on the coast
in my goddamn shirt back a bunch of high
leather boots
those Han Solo things that women were
wearing ah that was that was a wild one
oh my God that was wild when those
things hit around the fall look out yeah
every pumpkin patch out there yeah like
the outer rim I love that when it was
observed that everybody looked like Han
Solo yeah someone yeah 100 yeah I was
like what an amazing observation that
was yeah
um all right let's do one more then we
got a rapper up here uh let's do this
one this is from Kevin were you A Wheel
of Fortune a Jeopardy or a Price is
Right family
neither really really no never watched
game shows we like to watch together we
liked sitcoms okay what was the big one
I think wheeler like friends no well I'm
talking about maybe like cheers
yeah love cheers my family loved Frasier
okay yeah Frazier
um and that's probably around it I feel
like are your parents smart
um yeah I think so yeah my mom's really
she's smart my dad was really smart yeah
that makes stuff that makes sense they
also wear English and also I felt like
hello
oh Frasier it's like they love stuff
from on the BBC sure yeah they might as
well be Al Jazeera now yeah
you're reading yeah oh man that's
stunned there'd be like a new episode of
love joy on and he's like an antique
dealer slash uh criminal investigator
luxury was all right we used to watch
some of those old shows we used to watch
Faulty Towers yeah we used to watch are
you being served loved are you being
served [ __ ] say it's Benny Hill great
comedies man but the Frasier I felt like
was for like smarter parents sure we
didn't watch it I found it I mean I
always would see it I found it years
years later in reruns we'd watched
Married with Children Together We
watched cheers together we watch
Nightcore together mashed together uh me
and my mom used to watch Moonlighting
all the time yeah with Bruce Willis and
Cybil Shepard sexual tension between
them oh man he was [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
yeah best yeah but I feel
either you watch Jeopardy or you watch
Wheel of Fortune and price is right
that's where the line what time did that
come on like five or six what Jeopardy
yeah seven I think Jeopardy came on at
seven Wheel of Fortune hit at 7 30.
Price is Right was always in the morning
that's eleven yeah it was 11 o'clock
back when I was banging you'd get like
two three of those in the summer yeah
you're crushing a bowl of cereal I watch
them a lot in the summer yeah there's
certain programming I remember as a kid
when you stayed home and you were sick
oh yeah Price is Right is one and then
like a lot of Three's Company All in the
Family double shot of Hogan's Heroes
yeah that [ __ ] was awesome I remember
having an observation at that time Perry
where like all the commercials were like
get into key repair or AC repairing is
everyone at this time losers yeah
they're all home they're all unemployed
you've got the feet you're like this is
actually depressing what this is maybe I
am a piece of [ __ ] yeah do I have
mesothelioma they've replaced that with
mesothelioma things they replaced it
with reverse mortgages okay oh you watch
the [ __ ] TV during Sam Waters they're
trying to get you to give that house up
too sweet they want that money that they
want you to buy gold yes and just every
drug commercial you can possibly think
of oh yeah yeah I because I when I hung
out with my dad during the day when he
was sick we'd watch old westerns it was
forgot what channel it was and that was
on TV how to get into the bathroom the
roller coaster that goes up the stairs
type thing the channels of me TV I think
yeah I think it's called yeah they have
all those shows yeah it's this is like
funny when you start recognize you're
like oh this is a demographic sure
you're watching that yeah yeah of course
100 the tub with the door in it
so all the water comes up
you don't gotta step over slide right in
we gotta wrap it up gang the new podcast
is called lady Journey Sarah tolomash
Katie Hannigan congratulations do
yourselves a favor check it out yes
anything else you got coming up you want
the folks to know any no not anything
really okay yeah I I'm winding down
quietly quitting here
one of the funniest one of the best
Saratoga we love you to death Kippy what
do you got for him and the third show at
the Gramercy theater let's [ __ ] sell
that baby out shout out to the army of
garbage we [ __ ] love you we love you
to death we'll see you next week peace